something that might be
Hello. Hello. Hi. Wow, this music is loud. Hold on. Hold on.
Oh, there it's turning down. Okay. Hello. What's up, guys? I
don't know what we're going to do, honestly. I threw some time
up on the thing. Uh, might as well open up the Amaranth stream,
right? See what they were doing. Wait, is this the Nick stream
or the Amaran stream? I can't even tell. It must be the Amaran
stream. This is going for a long time.
kick.com/ammorrant. There it is. It's been around four hours
or some [__]
Nope. Hold on. Nick Wickley. What's Nick Wick Lee doing? Nuxenor
is live, too. Hold on. Let me see here. Is it on his VOD that
was popping off? Jesus. Want me to get Yeah, it is here. Okay.
Okay. Okay. This is the This is what J said. J said around here
some good happening. I'm probably gonna have to shut the music
off or definitely get it lower. Like way lower. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Yeah, I know. I know. Nick got high and fell asleep. Let's Let's
Let's track along with Nick getting high, falling asleep. Okay.
Leaving his stream on.
There's only one problem about the new car.
There's no goddamn air conditioning. I just thought of it. I
don't think there's AC. So, that's going to be uh a bit problematic.
Wow. You know, guys, amaranth. Amarant. Yo, what's up? I would
like to invite you to partake in an expedition for me. You just
yell amaranth at his wife. Amarant.
Amarant. Amarant. Uh, okay. All right. I guess so.
We still live. Uh, I just went live again. is easy. I went into
I went for a run and then I came back. I just came back or something.
Oh, Jesus. Really? Yeah. Like bang the door. Well, sorry.
Like squatting knock mixed with the You have security guards.
It should be fine. Yeah, I was so scared.
What the [__] Let's go. We got our hats on, boys.
I was going to invite you to do something, but I guess you're
going to be upset now. Why? What?
Let's go get high. Go buy drugs. What? Why would you say without
muting?
Let's go buy drugs, kids. What? Why are you dressed like you're
going to Malibu? I'm dressed like I'm a typical drug enjoyer.
Is that what they dress like? I think so. I don't know.
All right. Come with me. Where? To buy drugs. What are you talking
about? I was going to go buy some THC. What's that? It's like
a gummy.
Why? Trust me, it's not actually drugs. Is that even legal in
Exactly. It is. That's what I'm saying. It's legal. Boring. Where
are we going to go for that? I can't tell them, but nearby. Well,
is it legal then if it's You can't tell. Well, no. I I don't
want to get killed when I go there. Oh, you know, I don't want
to get robbed.
Oh, okay. That's fair. Okay. Um, why do you want me to go with
you? Because I love you. Does you want me to get robbed and killed,
too? Is that what it is? Oh my god. They kissed earlier on stream.
Suspicious, right? Like maybe I don't know what's going on with
you. I I can tell the fights are real, but also like what the
Why would you say that? I'm not serious. Yeah, but Oh, our viewers
still not showing. Cool. Oh my god. Got to love kick bro. I got
trauma. So, you got to be a little more sensitive.
You just make up all the rules. No. Is this going to make me
have bad dreams? I I just mean that like if if not saying bad
[__] was the rule, then you wouldn't have said if
you smoked a cigar, my dog would because I wasn't even smoking
a cigar. Okay, I'm not talking about that. I'm just saying my
bad dreams. I'm just They're uh they're negotiating not each
other. I guess be allowed to say bad [__] I'm not
I'm not saying it. What? Like you shouldn't be allowed to postulate
bad things. I didn't. You said it. I'm confused about the dog
stuff. Oh, okay. I'm saying I'm just saying if it if if it's
a rule for me, it's a rule for me. That's one of those things
that What? What is I'm not being funny. I'm literally saying
that if you are saying I got No, no, no. I mean the the joking
about getting killed and all that stuff. Well, yeah, but I was
saying it jokingly. You weren't even saying it. I know. I'm just
saying it's not real funny even for you. It makes me worried
the humans that you're going to get going to say it's stupid
for him to wear a shirt with his local gun club name on it, but
I forgot their address was posted in uh in all the home invasion
news articles. Oh, sure. I didn't even notice that
the timer is off. Is it off? Rather stay home, but thanks, bud.
Hey, go yourself. We're going. I would rather stay home. I just
finally got to make myself tea. You're going to pander to your
child? No, I've been taking care of animals all day. I know you
have. Hold on. I'm going to I'm actually just going to shut the
timer off for now.
I love antagonizing your chat. This guy BPD seems very up and
down, bro. Is BPD even real? Who knows? This guy is Yeah, he's
just bouncing off the walls. I
Dude, he's got something going on. Okay, he's got something going
on. Look at this dumb. You think something? I tend to think that
like all normal people are like one day away. All normal people
are one bad week away from being vulnerable. And all like vulnerable
people are like one interaction away from like snapping and and
coming off as like totally crazy. And I don't I don't know where
this guy was, but he is going to Bro, he is he is I don't even
know if I can feel bad for him cuz he's such an his wife. But
they don't look at all this dumb.
Oh no, they do. If you want to see the jokes, I screenshotted
some jokes for you if you want. T20 Max pal. I think you're sticking
your head in the rabbits or you're sticking your head in a hole
like an ostrich. That's okay. I just want to throw
safe. It's like all my chatters in here. You guys Well, so then
why hang out with these losers? You guys love watching this dude
sleep. You think it's a little weird. I am the reason she's even
here. Would you have gotten this far in the career on your own?
Definitely not. Where would you be right now? Probably married
with three kids to some loser. And she's married with no kids
to some loser. [__]
Rough. It's rough, guys.
Uh, not cool. Spruce Willis. No. Not cool. More ways than one.
All right. But, uh, if I don't come back, I love you. I love
you, too. And I'm sure someone in chat will swoop in. Y'all might
have missed it, but I flipped off her chat after I kissed her.
It's fine. I actually don't hate them. Even the ones who hate
me. I just think it's great because Okay, we're sciopsing them
guys. You know what I'm saying? The more annoying I act on her
stream. You're sciopsing them all. The more her I mean sciops
into thinking that this guy's a He's got He got me. Got all of
us. This is the best thing in the world. Are you thinking this
through with me? They should about being married. They should
be mad that she still hasn't left
Instead, I'm going to make them glued to her like gorilla glue
or some [__] I don't know. You get what I'm saying?
Like, like the more I act annoying. The more he is annoying and
unbearable, the more his fans will love his wife. Someone said,
"Check gen chat." What am I checking? You just want me to pull
this picture or what? Check Discord. Just this. I see it. Okay.
Do you want me to draw angles that he is like clearly leaning
in? She is like there's no lean. It's all lean from him. You
want to do a review or Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. What is
this? Okay. Athena. Okay. All right. And the more defensive they
get, the more they're actually just, you know, deepening their
feelings for her when otherwise without the conflict, they wouldn't
feel that way. And so, I'm actually, you know, making her fan
base tempered, if you will, like steel.
All right. No promises, guys. I don't know if I can get this
thing started. I've not driven it before. I don't even know if
they drove it here or if they just like winged it, you know,
or like I'm sure they Man, it's hot. Do these windows not roll
down? Holy mother of God. How do they do this in the 60s? Come
on. Got like a classic car. Bros. What kind of car is this? Has
to do something.
They just buy like a classic car and like park it there or something.
At least give me the windows to roll down. Oh my god. What the
Oh, man. I wish they took the tarp off since then. That's going
to take forever. Okay, hold on. I got more time. Are you serious?
The window really doesn't move, does it? Nope. Hold on. The windows
can come out or they can stay in. I don't know what she booms
are. Guys, I can't do this. It's too hot in here without windows.
Surely these windows work. Hold on. This is way worse. What the
Did we miss this one? I guess this would be from Amarad's
stream. What are we doing here, guys? What are we doing? What
are we doing? If these are not windows, what are they? I'm confused.
And it's getting damn hot in here just sitting in here. You see,
I would brave this, guys, if the windows open cuz then at least
when I start when we start going, it'll feel nice. But right
now, it don't feel nice. I'm like I'm a captain, right? So, I
can't leave it. So if it starts Hold on. Okay. Okay. Okay. I'm
just I'm looking at like Okay. I guess he comes back a little
bit later. Going to the weed store.
Gets back around 6 hours here. I want a program. Come on, bro.
Just don't understand the If you think this is fake, Orange Cush,
you're But it's fine. Again, uh the the only answer you need
to this is why um why did they go weeks and months being the
least entertaining or the least entertaining people on planet
Earth? Okay. And now they have like some amount of entertainment
entertainment when they have this meltdown. There's no way they
were capable of acting like this and they just weren't doing
it. What? To like sell you the bit? I don't think so.
I am Simple Jack. What the [__] Why? All right, here
we go. It's prime time, boys. I'm Simple Jack. I am Simple Jack.
Uh-huh. Has my life always been like this? What? What? Your wife
or your life? Oh, are you pretending to be high? Oh, no.
Oh, this is this thing about doing on stream, right? I guarant
somebody just in her chat said he's faking being high and ruined
the bit. Seems like you are. Was I not supposed to eat them all?
Did you empty them into a different thing? I'm banning every
one of you guys. Look, I made the profit. You're not nearly happy
enough. Seeming to be high.
Wait, wait, wait. So, you should like me being high then. Are
you high? No, it doesn't seem like you are. I'm not yet. I'll
be honest. They ruined it already. But let's both take one. No,
please. I don't want to.
Yeah. Um, the performiveness does not make it fake. The performiveness
is because they're on camera, right? They're playing to an audience.
People will do that. They're still obviously having very real
fights. Both be happy together. I'm already happy. No, you're
not. What the Oh, okay. So, I'm good, right? I don't got to do
anything different. I'm good. You're happy. Exactly. Really?
Exactly. Really? You are perfect the way that you are. I feel
like you're we're dueling streams right now. Oh, here's Oh, God.
That's fine. I don't care. No, don't don't don't. How about I
don't want one,
dude? the body language. I don't She's not that good an actress
to like curl in like this and make herself small.
Please. No. Please use drugs.
Please use drugs. I don't want to. Please use all these drugs.
No. Hold on. Maybe it's not quite as bad as I thought, but it's
still pretty [__] guys. I'm going to go in there
and ban everyone who told you. Bro, why do they eat like this?
Why do they eat like this? They have so much money, dude. Risk
the skitsos breaking in and hire a private chef. Stop paying
for security. Risk the skitsos. Hire a private chef. No one told
me. You just aren't very good at acting.
What the, man? To be fair, I was not quite ready yet. Oh, okay.
You had rehearsed? No, I was like getting amped up into it and
then I saw you instantly. Oh, this is great. Can I eat them all?
I don't care. They're not mine. What would happen? I don't know.
Okay. Awkwardly hot. Hold on. Will you ever piss? I'll have one
piece. I have munchies now. Will you ever have one of these with
me, please? One day. Uh, we'll see. No, it's that shirt. I feel
like I'm on shrooms. I think he's just got a lot. Oh, Jesus.
I think he's just got a lot of outfits like that. [__]
I need water. Oh, I went rant. I have not drunk enough water.
One second. On your birthday. Yes. Listen, I'll think about it.
Listen, I'm actually in the same boat as you. I'm super super
super You know, I've never used drugs except that one time with
acid. So, I'm in the same boat as you. We're both newbies at
this. I think it'd be fun. How about it? I'm not making promises.
No, you don't like to do things with me. Not drugs. I think it
would deepen. No, it's cuz I am really content with the feeling
of being sober and I don't want to experience other I feel like
if you're really content being sober, you wouldn't be so wound
up all the time. I'm not wound up all the time. My voice is just
recovering still and I went through some trauma recently. It's
not all the time. It's only been a few months. Talking about
the robbery, right? Yes. Oh, that's so good. How long till it
hits me? I could hit you faster if you want. Okay. Uh, dude,
you know what? You know what I don't get? Okay, I'm looking at
Kick right now. I'm seeing a lot of zero viewer streams again.
Whatever the going on here, you know the there's like almost
a thing about Kick. I'm I won't complain, but it's like cuz obviously
they pay like a lot for like not massive viewership or anything.
Like objectively I've got a sweet deal. Okay, objectively I've
got a sweet deal. But like sometimes now it's like dude I don't
feel I wouldn't feel justified at all complaining about this,
right? I like I just don't feel justified complaining about it
because I get paid a lot all the time and they've been paying
me really well for like months. I So like but now I feel like
I don't have any ability to really complain or be annoyed cuz
like what am I going to do? I'm be like dude I couldn't even
stream. You guys really me over like yeah we probably paid you
like three or 400% of what you were really going to make on any
other platform. So but but I'm like annoyed and I don't feel
like I'm justified in being annoyed. It's weird. You know how
this is. If I made that joke, if I made that joke, they would
Does your dashboard show viewership? No, I don't think I'm going
to get paid for this stream at all, which is whatever. It's not
going to be that long. It's fine. If I hit you, though, I just
mean move my chair a little bit and tap knees. I know how fragile
you are. Oh, did I hurt you just now? I'm not sure. You know
what they call that? A classy misdemeanor. It is a unwanted physical
contact.
First degree. I see. If you grab my dick, it's third degree.
Oh, make sure they were to do that then. Hey, dude. I Oh, there's
like a thing going on here where like I feel like I've been in
something akin to this where it's like, you know, the relationship's
over. You like, you know, there's like long a maybe not a long
time. You spent like time together. Maybe you're friends before
or something. you like don't hate each other and you can have
moments where it's like fine, but you know it's over and you
know like h it's like purgatory. It's actually purgatory. It's
the worst. I took one whole one. Uhoh. And it's funny cuz the
lady at the shop hit hard. Be careful. Wait, he definitely takes
more if he took 1,000 gram, right? Or 1,000 milligs, rather.
Not thousand g. Jesus Christ. A kilogram. Did you see? The lady
at the shop said, "You should start with half." And then she
goes, "But no one ever listens to me." And so we kept that tradition
alive. I'll report back, I guess, in 30 minutes. So people will
tell you you can't really um overdose on edibles. Dude, the one
time I took edibles like late at night, I was like, "Oh, hey,
I I think I'll just fall asleep." I think it was like it was
like a pack of like the candies, right? I like took them. I just
remember like trying to go to sleep and like the veins in my
eyes were
pounding so heavily I couldn't sleep. I should never have done
it. I But I didn't have any experience with really like taking
edibles at all. And I took like too much and my dude I could
just feel it was like my eyes were like absolutely like oh it
was like something was squeezing them on and off. That's your
blood pressure going nuts. But my blood pressure wasn't that
high. My heart rate wasn't that high. Maybe my my blood pressure
might have been high. I don't know. But I just took too much.
I don't think it was like that bad. I didn't I didn't check my
blood pressure. But uh like it wasn't like my heart was pounding.
Like I did check my uh my my pulse. My my heart wasn't like pounding
or anything. Like I don't know like 90 which is like elevated
but it's not like crazy. I don't know. Is it 30 minutes? I'm
not sure. I'm just assuming
No, no, no, no, no. Orange cush. It was not in my ears at all,
which makes me think it was not that. It wasn't in my ears at
all. And I've had that before, but it wasn't that. It was my
eyeballs. My eyeballs were like I could feel my heartbeat in
my eyeballs. It was crazy. She's not on by bands. She hasn't
been on for for a while, just FYI. Oh, what the what? The windows
do open. Oh my god. What the? I couldn't open them cuz it's so
hot inside. Why would the guys? It just magically opened on its
own.
What the That car, man. Dude, you know how long I spent buy it?
Did you money away? Doesn't know how to work it. It doesn't have
power string. Doesn't have AC buttons fall out of it. Ugly.
You don't You think it's ugly? Yeah, it's pretty ugly. I thought
you let your color green small. Wait, I'm very confused about
your aesthetic.
I'll just say I'm not going to make like too many jokes about
this, but it sure would be funny if uh certain somebody we used
to be associated with had to go and inform people that they just
moved to a new neighborhood. Seems like that's increasingly a
possibility recently for reasons unknown. I I'm not actually
going to say anything else. Okay. I didn't want to say anything
on stream today. Now we're just in late hours. It's fine. Okay,
excuse me. Uh, hi. My my name's Steve and I just moved to the
neighborhood. This is like picture perfect Ralph Lauren [__]
for resort wear. How do you not like that? Looks like a kind
of beat up. That That's the whole point. It's from the ' 60s.
Yeah, I know. But I thought it was What the? Like a little bit
longer. Come on. I bet you if you saw a picture of it in a Ralph
Lauren store, you'd be like, "Oh, that's so cute. That's so charming."
It's a British car from the '60s. I thought that it would be
longer. It's kind of like square. I could have gotten it longer.
I just didn't. Yeah, it's kind of small. What's up?
Where are you going to take it? Yeah, I had fun with it. Let
me tell you about that. Dude, I was in there for like an hour
with them being like, "There's no I can't open the windows. It's
so hot in here. It's so hot in here." And then I walked by and
the windows just like are slid open. I'm like, "Yeah, sure."
Okay. Your chat heard. I pressed the but So, I got It just slid
up. I got it. In the car. I got it started finally. It's not
marked. So, so look, I did do my research, okay? Okay. But it's
not my fault that like in the vehicle that is on YouTube, they
have everything marked very clearly and and there's like letters
and stuff under it. On mine, there's nothing. It's just It looks
like you just walked off a Quinton Tarantino movie. How do I
look? Much the same, I would hope.
Switches that go up and down, up and down, up and down. And this
gear, this uh Why these look nothing? Did you not get the same
Well, I I think they just literally put that on. So, I actually
think that they're trying to get that authentic feel and the
one that is obviously on YouTube is just for like literally for
the teaching video, right? And so, that makes it extra complicated.
And so, at one point, I pressed the button. So, so I I get the
car started and I couldn't figure out how to move and then I
figured it out. So, I rolled it forward because that's what I
wanted to do because I want to get out of the way so that we
can back our vehicles out still, right? Cuz now, right now, we
can back all the other vehicles out because it's not in the way
anymore. So then I'm like, "Cool." And then I'm thinking like,
"Okay, this is easy." You know, foot full down on the clutch,
you know, all down on the brake and then turn the key. I turn
the key and then I pull it out. The key is not in the car anymore,
but the car is still running. And I was like, "What the [__]
There's no off button." I was like pressing all these buttons
like a goddamn monkey, you know? And just when I thought I was
going to die, I was like, "Wait, I'm going to pull up YouTube
and I'm going to like, you know, watch a tutorial." And then
I noticed my phone had like 1% battery. And I was like, "Shit,
I got to call you with that 1%." Cuz if I don't call you and
my phone dies, I'm stuck in there all night until you walk by.
So anyways, I call you, you bring Hey, he's like, at least now
that he's like maybe a little high or he's getting there, he's
yapping, but it's not yapping and like telling her she's wrong
about everything. He's just yapping in general. the thing. I
watched some videos. It's still rough. And I was like, "Okay,
I think I got it." So, I pressed the button on the dash. I'll
sh you not. I'll even show you where it is. The button just fell
out. I pressed a button and the button just fell out. I was like,
"Good junk." I was like, "Do I need that?" And then I got saved
by the most unlikely fact. It's because I own a Rolls-Royce that
I'm not in that vehicle right now because do you remember the
Rolls-Royce AC button? It's push pull. It's the only thing I
know that has a pool button. And so I was like, "Oh, this this
car is British, too. Maybe it's a goddamn British thing." And
so then the stop start switch, which I kept pushing and pushing
and pushing and nothing happened. Right. I pulled it. It turned
it off. And so it's pull to turn off, push to turn on. Idiots.
And by idiots, I mean me. Yeah. I never would have even tried
that. I not already know. There's a better version of this that
looks like techone that I think somehow more embodies this situation.
But this is also Yes. Yeah. Dude. Ah. What? Ah. Ah, I should
keep those pictures up. It's good thing you're rich or else jump
scare multiple times.
But it also, if you weren't rich, you wouldn't have bought that
thing. I'd also be uglier.
No. Is that Does that mean you're not going to me tonight? Is
that what it means? Is that what it means? Wait, wait. I have
a soundboard just for this. I have a soundboard just for this.
Is that what it means? I didn't say that. Oh, you didn't. Okay,
you didn't say that. All right, I'll leave. Okay, I'm going to
leave on a high note. Am I the only one whose eyes are watering?
It's like a natural
I My eyes my eyes just start watering when I listen to this man
speak. It's crazy. It's like Is anybody Someone cutting onions?
What the is
just guns everywhere, guys? Send that sure seems I'm pretty sure
this is a federal crime, isn't it? You're just running around
with guns while you're on a thousand milligrams of edibles. Isn't
this uh Isn't that a problem? Got it. Uh, I took it to the gun
range to get it cleaned and um, what do we call it? Uh, the the
sights zeroed in. And then I got this holster for her staccato.
Be on. What are you doing, girl? What are you in the room? The
dark room for Biggie. Oh, I see you. Peggy, what are you doing?
Come here. Come on. Let's go. Big. My daughter. My dove
daughter. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. What an adventure. Okay, so how
long did I fill this [__] To be fair, Hunter Biden
got cuz he was already on drugs when he filled out his form.
I think with uh with this I don't I just assume it's illegal
to like keep to do edibles. Maybe I'll see if I can fool you
guys into thinking
I'm a certain way.
Damn it, dude. That would have been grade A content, dude. Wait,
also just for the sake of knowing, how far apart in terms of
species are doves and pigeons? They can't they they can't be
that far apart.
Ruin. It's fine. It's fine. You know what? Here's what I'll do
next time. I got to figure out a way to do this. I think next
time what I'll do is I won't even tell y'all I'm about to do
Colomb is a bird family consisting of doves and pigeons. It is
the only family in the order of columnforms. These are stoutbodied
birds with small heads, relatively short necks and slender bills
that in some species feature fleshy sears. They feed largely
on plant matter feeding on seeds, fruit, and
foliage. Look, pigeons and doves. They're like close. I knew
they were close. Do that cuz then no one would know, right? No
one would be cognizant enough to know. Y'all just think that
I like showing y'all simple Jack videos.
You know what? No, the real ones will know. If y'all see a Simple
Jack video, I'm about to do some dumb [__] I
Okay. Okay. So, let's see what was Oh,
let me see if I got more. So, let's see what is being said here.
I know. The dove cooing is so soothing to me. Yeah, I love the
bird. Hold on. Apparently. All right. Well, so how soon should
Wait, how long does he stream for? I'm so confused. Did he actually
go to sleep? Did he say he was going to sleep? That like something
he did,
Hold on.
Is there such a thing is too high to
Go to bed like right now.
You going to go to bed right now?
He's so
He like had a thought coming through there and he just was like,
"Oh, [__]
Oh, that was
psychotic to behave this way after the blow up they had. It is.
It It actually shows you that that blowup was like something
that they could just go to the next day and be like whatever,
right? Like that must be a blowup they've had at least once before
on that level, if not multiple times before, right? It just hasn't
been on stream.
Oh, [__] you guys.
He's able to drink water, so that's pretty good.
But I must go.
Hold on. What do you say?
I must return to my people.
I'm gonna check out Amaran's stream after this real quick.
Yeah. Yeah. 1309. Yep. Yep. Yep. I got to faith this follower.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. That's the next section I'm watching.
React to the new Kanye song.
Wait, is World War World War II isn't new? It's one month old.
Is there a new Kanye song?
But world World War II is old. Is there a new Yay song? Someone
said there's a new Yay song, but you guys trying to fool this
guy into thinking that this is a new Yay song. Up, dude. He just
walked off. Guy just walked off.
put the lights out
and just off to bed.
Change the name of the LP from to World War II. Okay.
And just gone. Okay. All right. Uh, ammo stream. Ammo stream
time. Ammo Rance. Ammo Rance. Here we go. Here we go. Yeah, he's
just left his stream on. We're going to watch the last little
bit of this guy right here. A
1309 right here at the end. Listen. No. All right. I'm feeling
it. Do you feel it? How do you feel? A little bit. I'm about
to go do some more. What? Why can we watch the bikini stream?
I have no idea what you're talking about, Zezy. You're a weirdo.
Do a weird one, Zezy. I supposed to just do like half of one.
You did a whole one night and do more. Yeah, but if you just
started to feel it, you should let it run its course a bit first.
I'm addicted. Well, I know you're I don't know who Ted is, though.
Is that your last name, Ted? You better not. First name, dick.
You better not know who Ted is. Listen, next time you get a yoga
instructor, did he just Did he just sniff her? Was that all he
did there? Is that your last? It looked like he was like going
for a kiss and then he just like inhaled. He did the B. His name
Ted. You better not. You better not know who Ted is. Listen,
next time you get a yoga instructor, run it by me first.
You understand that? I'm never going to do yoga again. You don't
worry about it. I never wanted to see a yoga mat in my life.
What have Mats?
The gym probably. I don't know.
Um I'm tired. I'm gonna go to bed. What? Yeah, I woke up early
and I'm going to go wake up early in the morning. Did you work
out? I've been lifting stuff all day. You know what I'd like
to do? Go do another gummy. So you told me a day ago after.
I'm too tired. I've been working all day. If you had helped me,
it would
I'm sorry. Like it feels it feels real is it feels like she actually
I don't want to be the like I mostly the thing I like criticize
is the um how would I put it like the verbal abuse. Okay. I don't
want to be like the white knight who's like oh she's so grossed
out by him. Oh look. But like she does pull away. I feel like
she pulls away. Like watch she like creates distance. I don't
want to have to
look. I'm too tired. She like pulls away. He comes in and she
like goes
away. I don't want to be the the simp guy who's like, "Oh, he
shouldn't be touching her. I've been working all day. If you
had helped me, but I did it all
I wish you'd do the yoga by yourself. I'm never going to do it
again." So,
once is enough. Yeah. Once was too many. So, you agree? Yep.
It was too much. It was too much. I made a really funny joke
earlier. Did you? Oh, it was so good. It was so funny. It was
so funny. Um, I was like, "Guys, this is I should do stand up,
honestly." Okay, so they heard it already, but Oh, he should
do stand up. Oh my god, he should do stand up. I was like, "Guys,
this is We hired so many goddamn people, but no one's here today.
Jacob has food poisoning, right? Katie is expecting to get married
and proposed to, and she's at Disney, right? Hannah got her car
broken into." H right. And then I go, Chris. Well, Chris left
to pursue his dream job of becoming a yoga instructor. And then
I go, where's the lie? Chris literally left
because just I thought it was Kell. Didn't Kelly make up the
thing that like he was sucking the soul from her? I feel like
one of them is slowly like losing their vitality completely like
slowly losing their soul. And Nick is just sitting here. Amaranth
is like she doesn't look as bad there, but Nick is just he's
doing perfect. Okay, he's he's doing so well of being a yoga
instructor. You're so good, baby. You should be a stand-up comedian.
Wait, where was there a joke there? Chris Well, Chris left to
pursue his dream job of becoming a yoga instructor. And then
I go, where's the lie? Chris literally left because of being
a yoga instructor. You're so good, baby. Dude, I don't even want
to soundboard this guy.
All right, I just had to find the right one. Dude, what is he?
You should be a stand-up comedian. Have your own Netflix special.
And all I do is roast my wife for 30 minutes. It's so funny though.
It's a good one. The punch line is Chris is a guy that they apparently
it sounds like he might have fired this guy who did yoga with
his wife. That's what it sounds like. Does this make me hate
every woman that did that's ditched after a rough patch? This
lady is locked the in. Wait, what do you mean? What do you mean?
All right. I'm the one to pay. I'm tired. But you can stream
on both of our channels. I don't care. Honestly, you know what?
Why don't you shout me out? Help me grow. You said that's cheating,
though. You said you wanted to do it yourself to prove a point.
If I do that, you'll never know if you could have done it yourself.
Let me explain something to you. Okay. Within the boundaries
of the rule are included the fact that if you can get a big streamer
to shout you out, that ain't cheating. And I'm getting a big
streamer to shout me out. You know, you know what? That's true.
Can we get that added to the post though? 50% of your revenue
going forward. Well, I'm about to become the next ninja. Girl,
that's why I'm about to leave you. You told me that that's what
would happen if you use my platform to look at this, guys. Look
at this woman. She's already trying to take half of what I have
in the You just told me the other day that's what will happen.
Listen, I plan to leave you in the dust financially. Okay. I
know. I got that. You are going to be You think I don't know
that? I'm highly aware. You are going to have to Why are you
pushing me away? This looks really bad. Cuz your breath smells
like weed.
What? Breath smells like the edible. Wait. Wait till you know
what else tastes like. Okay. I'm feeling it right. Come on. I
guess so. Dude,
make sure you don't want to take advantage of this. That's his
semen, by the way, in case you guys didn't get that. He's a stand
up. I'm a stand-up comedian. Okay. Couple comedians going back
and forth. His semen might taste like the edible. Actually, good.
Just see how it affects you and maybe you can replicate it another
night when you figure out the right dose that makes you feel
the best. Are you going to be tired tomorrow, too? Uh, who knows
if I have to do everything alone? Probably. You going to help
me tomorrow? Um, what day is tomorrow?
It's Thursday. Probably. I could. Okay, we'll see. I'm not I
keep trying. I'm too happy right now. You know what's going to
happen? He's going to Here's high actually. Okay. What he actually
did is he shut his stream off and then he turned the video on
of me reviewing why he's an abusive piece of [__]
and he's going to be high and he's going to watch that and he's
going to cry and realize he's been a complete piece of [__]
to his wife and he's totally going to change. Okay, he's going
to change entirely. He's going to be a new man, turn over a new
leaf, okay? He's true to right and they're actually going to
be happy going forward and I'll be invited when they renew their
vows. Okay, now that I might make a joke that I will regret.
I was about to make a joke. I'm just not going to do it. I'm
not going to do it. All right. I'm not going to do it. Don't.
Oh,
boy. Oh. All right.
Good night, chat. I'll see you tomorrow. Me and my chat are examining
your ear. Well, you think your dick could fit in there or what,
dude?
She Dude. Okay, that's how you know he's high. That actually
was funny as [__] Who should be the standup comedian?
I'm like a All right. Dude, that was the best joke I heard all
night, guys. You don't even know how good that joke was. I don't
joke about someone's Okay, I joke about it. She just listen.
That was the best joke I heard all night. All right. [__]
All right. I should go to bed before I stand you up more. I literally
can't tell.
I can't There's something about Amaran's face. It's like uh she's
like the Mona Lisa of I can't tell if she's like laughing or
crying at any given moment. I don't know. You know how Mona Lisa
might be smiling or might not be smiling? I can't tell if Em's
about to break down in tears or if she's laughing at any given
moment. I don't know what it is. What are we looking at here?
It could be both. That's the best heard all night. I don't know.
[__] All right. I should go to bed before I stand
you up more.
Oh my god, that was lethal. A. All right, I should go to bed
before I stand you up more. All right, good night, dude.
Nice night. See you tomorrow. Bye-bye. We are un unironically
getting a glimpse of the little charm he may actually have that
kept them together this long. Uh, dude, that's what I said. BB
Poison. Uh, the dynamic that works between them is when Amaranth,
look, it's uh Smug Kelly. Smug Kelly in the chat. But the dynamic
they have that works is when she's like kind of mocking him and
keeping his ego down and he has enough ego to like be okay with
being mocked. But the issue is he's been so fragile the whole
time that like when he gets mocked he like loses his right. Yeah.
He gets like he gets mocked and he just like totally crumbles.
If he could deal with being mocked it's like it's a little bit
endearing. Okay. A little bit endearing. Anyway, I don't know.
There's probably more stuff from today. I haven't really looked
at all the time stamps and should give me a second. Let me see.
Let me see. Let me see. Hold on. Oh, she refused to take the
edibles with him. I'm not making He saw this a little bit. So,
I'm in the same boat as you. We're both newbies at this. I think
it'd be fun. How about it? I'm not making promises. Well, you
don't like to do things with not drugs. I think it would deepen.
No, it's cuz I am really content with the feeling of being sober
and I don't want to experience other If you like if you were
really content being sober, you wouldn't be so wound up all the
time. I'm not wound up all the time. My voice is just recovering
still and I went through some trauma recently. It's not all the
time. It's only been a few months. Talking about the robbery.
Yes. Oh, that's good. Chad, how long till it hits me? I could
hit you faster if you wanted. You know how this is. If I made
that joke, if I made that joke, they would me. If I hit you though,
I just need to move my chair a little bit and tap knees. Yeah,
I know how fragile you are. Oh, did I hurt you just now? I'm
not sure. You know, they call that a classy misdemeanor. There's
a unwanted physical cont from the other side. First degree.
They see you. You grab my It's third degree. Make sure to do
that. Hey, I one hole on. It's funny cuz the lady at the shop
hit hard. Be careful. lay at the shop, dude. Unfortunately, like
basically the whole time it would just work like the whole time.
Hold on.
Oh, what am I looking for? I want to experience other I feel
like if you were really content being sober, you would I could
hit you faster. It's right here as we go. As we go right here,
he like keeps following. Uhoh. It's funny, but the lady in the
shop going to hit hard. Be careful right here. when he appears
here. That's the feeling I have is just like she goes, but no
one ever listens. Bro, stop following me. Uh, all right. We'll
report back, I guess, in 30 minutes or so. I don't know. Is it
30 minutes? I'm not sure. I'm just assuming she's not on by,
man. She hasn't been on for for a while. FYI. Oh, what the what?
Oh, what was that? What was that? Wait, what was that? Wait,
what's this?
You are a girl. I am a boy.
We have all that in common,
darling. May I Okay. Okay. All right, dude. Hold on. Of course.
Why would you open them? Cuz it's so hot inside. Why wouldn't
they open, guys? It just magically opened on its own.
Damn. Did you hear something? You know how long Why did you buy
it? Did you bonk money away?
Doesn't know how to work it. Doesn't have power. Doesn't have
AC. buttons fall out of it. It's ugly.
Yeah, it's pretty ugly. I thought the color green and bigger
small. Wait, this is like picture
It just looks like it's kind of beat up.
That's the whole point. It's What is happening with the sound?
Yeah, I know. But it just looks like it's kind of beat up. Like
a little bit longer. Kind of awesome. I bet you if you saw a
picture of me a Ralph Lauren story, you like, "Oh, it's so cute.
It's so charming." Like a little bit longer. It's kind of boxy.
I bet you if you saw a picture of it British car from the '60s.
I thought that it would be longer. It's kind of like square.
I could have gotten it longer. It's a British car from the 60s.
Until you walk by. So anyways, I call you. You bring the thing.
I watch some videos. It's still rough. And I was like, "Okay,
I think I got it." So I pressed the button on the dash. I'm I'll
sh you now. We saw this. We saw this from the other side already.
The button just fell out. I pressed a button and the button just
fell out. I was like, a hunk of junk. I was like, do I need that?
And then I got saved, bro. Okay, I you know what?
I I don't know. I don't know if there's much else here. Like
we watched a decent amount of it. There's probably more stuff.
Maybe we'll cover it tomorrow. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Thanks
for coming on tonight, guys. I don't know if I'm going to I don't
think there's anything else. There's like I I have some other
stuff, but I'm probably going to cover it tomorrow. So, let me
see. What's the What do the kick dashboard say? I just want to
make up that 45 minutes or whatever. We went an hour. I I didn't
want to not do the whole the whole time that got paid for. I
think Schlle might already be asleep, but I wanted to make sure
I came back and did all the time. All the time. All the time.
All the time. Okay, we'll be back tomorrow. Um, okay. I do not
want to get you guys too excited, okay?
Oh, but I got I got a message back from one of the YouTube rep
people to like set something else up. I don't want to get you
like way way too excited, but like for the love of God, could
we catch a break? Could we catch a break? Could we could we just
catch a break? I By the way, I emailed this guy. I emailed this
guy like uh like three weeks ago. I basically was like, "Hey,
um put me back on YouTube or I'm gonna kill myself." And he finally
emailed me back. So,
go. Email me back. He's like, "Did you do it yet?" I'm like,
"Nah, let's set up a meeting."
Okay. All right. By the most
Yes. Yes. Not actually. I think I was just like, "Hey, please
can we talk again? Please, please, please. Please. Yeah. Anyway,
you got to play the game. Well, we'll see. Uh hopefully it goes
well. You got to one One could hope. One could hope. One could
hope. One could hope. Okay. All right. Yeah, he just emailed
me like earlier tonight. Like four hours ago was when he emailed
me back. So, it was like during the stream before I just noticed
it. Oh, that's cool. Okay. Raid Nick.
Dude, if I raid Nick, is it just going to be a raid with zero
viewers? The What even happens when you raid with you raid somebody
with zero viewers? What's h what happens? The hell? Oh, I literally
can't even host a channel right now. It thinks I have no viewers,
so I can't host. I'm not allowed to host right now. Cool, cool,
cool, cool, cool, cool, cool, cool. Hold on. Slashhost Nick Wickly.
Maybe it'll work if I do it through the console. Nope, it do
not. It do not. By tomorrow, you mean later today you'll stream.
Um, actually, I think you mean later today. Technically. Technically,
you might mean later today. Actually, yeah, probably later today.
True. That's probably true. You can't send us away. I can try.
Hold
on. Nick
Wicklyhost Nick Wick
Leehost. Username Nick Wickly. Nothing. Nothing. Nothing. Okay.
All right, that be it. That'd be it. That'd be it. That'd be
all. Okay. Love you guys. Oh, wait. Nickwick TV. Oh, hold on.
It's Nickwick TV now. Nicknickwick
TV. Nothing. Nothing
happened. Hold on.
Slhostnickwick TV. Nothing happens
Unlucky. Okay. Okay. Uh, yeah. So, I'm going to go to bed. I'll
talk to you guys tomorrow. Bye. Bye. Bye. Also, also, just to
be clear for all the people who complained about the mod making
decisions today. Uh, you're wrong. You're just all wrong. Okay.
Sorry. Oh, I Hold on. I was going to have a whole thing. I wanted
to argue with people a little bit or not argue, just ask. I think
there's I'm not like something of a victim blamer, okay?
But I think when you end a relationship with somebody to go into
a space you know they share and start talking about the new people
you're trying to date or like within days while you know they're
going through stuff. I feel like when you're trying to make somebody
crumble and then they do crumble and they do something crazy.
I don't think you are blameless there. Even though I do not believe
you should have the same punishment as that person. Okay. I do
believe there is something to be said for like please don't come
to me and tell me that you didn't do anything when you clearly
did something. Okay. I'm just I'm just saying right. It's like
the uh it's like when I when I joked about Kelly um taunting
Destiny when Destiny's like I have all his contact information
and Kelly's like do something with it. I'm like Destiny has a
gun to my head and Kelly's like yeah do it [__] do
it [__] It's like technically if Destiny shoots me,
he's mostly to blame, but also there can be other factors that
go into that. It's like listen, deescalate, right? Do your part.
Deescalate anyway. Anyway, I don't know. I don't know. Am I being
too generic? You guys know what I'm saying? Yeah. It's like I
just think when you're trying to make some when you're trying
to affect a result, even if the result is like bad, I think probably
I feel like what what are you what are we you're not like the
biggest victim in the world. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. That's how
it is. Okay. Anyway, good night. Good night. That's my thoughts.
Going to deeds. No, I'm good. I'm good. Have a good night, guys.
We'll see you later. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. You're talking
about you, Ukraine, Russia, right? No, obviously not. Um, also
those are like states a little harder to to justify that. You
can like understand how somebody would crash out like in a personal
sense and uh states don't get that opportunity to crash out in
a statewide sense. Okay, that's why we're mad about Israel. Talking
about Wolf Gand. Yes, I'm talking about Wolf Gand. Yep. Wolf
Gand was asking for it. You heard it here first. Wolf Gand was
actually asking for it. Yep. The whole time. The whole time.
The whole time. Entire time. Okay. Have a good night,